DAN MILLER: My
name is Dan Miller.
I work for Unity Technologies
as an XR evangelist.
So I mostly focus on AR and VR.
But I've done a lot of mobile
game development in the past
and built a lot of
Android applications.
And what I want to do
today is talk a little bit
about some best practices
for Unity development
inside the Android ecosystem.
So there's going to
be some fairly kind
of basic or easy wins, as
well as talking about things
you can do, and how to
understand and start
some of the debugging
process, as well as some newer
features and things
that are maybe still
a little bit in early access.
And if you are publishing your
game in the near coming months,
you'll see some of
these things starting
to come out, and just some
strategies that you can take
advantage of as a developer.
So before I get
started, I want to ask
how many people
have heard of Unity,
or are aware of the
Unity editor or engine.
All right, lots of hands there.
So if you're not aware,
Unity is a piece of software
or a tool for writing
interactive applications.
And we've done a
lot of work to make
it very easy to develop
and create your games
and publish them to stores,
like the Google Play Store.
There's actually
integrated settings
in the publish
settings so you can
set up a lot of your
things, build out your APK,
and push it up right away.
All right.
And so what I want
to do first is just
go through what I
call some easy wins.
Some basic techniques
to consider
when publishing and
developing your application
within the Unity editor.
Next, I'm going to talk about
ADB, the Android Debug Bridge,
how you can set that up,
and how you can utilize
that to get some information
about what's actually happening
with your application running
on Android back to your PC.
And after that, I'm just
going to talk a little bit
about reducing the APK
size on your application
so that you can make
it easier for users
to get a hold of your
app, try it right away,
and not have to wait
for a long download time
or downloading it over
something like Wi-Fi.
All right, so let's start
with some easy wins.
The first thing I want to talk
about is just texture atlasing.
And what this is is it's
really common in 2D development
where you pack all
of your sprites
together in a single texture.
What this allows you to
do is reduce draw calls.
And you can then
kind of split it up
to use different
little sprite sheets
for each individual sprite,
but have them all packed here
on a certain texture.
And while this works
really well for 2D,
it's also pretty common
to do it for 3D as well.
You can see there's two
little bug creatures here.
One's more of a dragonfly,
and one's a ladybug.
But they're actually using
the same texture here
and just referencing
different parts of it.
So when you're creating
things like 3D assets,
you can consider laying out the
UVs on a shared UV sheet here,
and then reference the
same texture to, again,
just reduce draw calls, and
optimize your application.
Now, the other
thing to consider is
how you're compressing
your textures,
and what sort of shaders you're
using to render your 3D models.
And again, this is
more on the 3D side,
but does apply a
little bit to 2D.
So one thing to keep
in mind is right now,
inside the Unity editor,
the standard shader
is PBR, or
Physically-Based Rendering.
And this is meant to reflect
the lighting conditions
and features in the real world.
We have reflective
surfaces that are
able to reflect the
environment around them,
similar to what we have that
exist in the real world.
Things like different lighting
settings and stuff like that.
Now, depending on what sort
of application you're making,
or what sort of stylistic choice
you're making with your models,
it's not always really
appropriate to have these PBR
materials and have all these
different options for what
you need.
You can see here that these
two bugs are a little bit more
stylized or cartoon-like,
so it doesn't necessarily
make sense to have
them fully going
through the processes that's
required to render them based
on physically-based properties.
So what I've done
here is I actually
have two different materials
that are backed-- one
by the standard shader, and one
by a much lighter shader here.
And you can see
the settings here.
And even without
fully understanding
what's happening at
the shader level,
you can easily see the contrast
between the differences
of the instructions or the maps
that are associated with this.
And you'll see here on one side
we have just a simple texture
assignment.
And on the other, while we
have that texture assignment,
we also have all these
different settings.
But I haven't actually
adjusted them all at all.
And if I go back
there, you can almost
barely see a
difference between how
the lighting and the
rendering is set up here.
So something to really
keep in mind, depending
if you're using 3D models and
the actual stylistic approach
that you want to
your assets, is just
considering using a
more lightweight shader
or a mobile-optimized shader.
So within Unity in
the material settings,
you can actually drop down,
choose the shader that's
backed for that material.
And there is a specific
mobile one as well.
So really consider this when
setting up your 3D models.
And the last thing-- and this is
something that's kind of unique
to the Android platform--
is, within the Unity editor,
in the application namespace
and API, we actually
have an is genuine check.
And what you can do
here is, in your code,
you can go and check
if the APK is genuine.
And what it means
to be genuine is
if it is directly downloaded
from the Google Play Store
and has not been altered.
Now, we all know that APK can
be fairly easily distributed.
And this is really helpful
for testing or letting
your buddy try out your
game before it's released.
And what you can
do in your app is
that you can use
this is genuine check
to potentially restrict some
features or things like that.
So you could restrict
access to the in-app store
that's in your thing.
You could also restrict
access to maybe certain levels
or something if the is
genuine check is not passed.
Now, something to keep
in mind is that this
is a fairly expensive call.
So if you are using it, consider
using it at a single point
before you kind of
show different features
or applications.
And don't try to call
this every frame, as that
will get pretty expensive.
All right, and now I just
want to dive a little bit
into debugging.
And this is kind of a process
that I go through when
developing any apps on Android.
It is a little bit
more rudimentary
but kind of helps
you get a base start
to understand what's going
on and how to integrate this.
And so for this, I use ADB.
So ADB is the
Android Debug Bridge.
And what it is is it's
basically a robust command line
tool that allows you
to link in directly
to your Android device.
You can do this through
USB by just plugging it
into your device, opening
up the ADB console,
and then there's a lot
of associated commands,
as well as flags that you can
use to get information back.
Now, one thing to keep in
mind is that ADB gives you
a lot of information back.
And if you're not
using any filtering,
it'll be hard to even really
read or understand what's
happening, as information
just continually flies through
in the console itself.
So what can you do for this?
Well, you can actually
set a specific Unity flag.
But again, I just want
to kind of highlight here
that, as a developer,
when you're connecting
your device via ADB
or via your computer,
you can do it the USB.
And if you're using
a more modern phone,
one thing to keep in mind is
that you will need to unlock
and look at your phone
and actually allow
those USB debugging.
And that's an option in
the developer settings.
So if you guys are
developing for Android,
hopefully your Android device
is already in developer mode.
And there's a little
checkbox there
for allowing USB debugging.
And then from here, you can
connect it to your computer,
and then start hooking up ADB
and getting some information
back.
It is also available via Wi-Fi.
And you can do this via
the connected editor
in the console
window within Unity.
So as I mentioned, there's
actually a flag or a callback
here.
And you can do a -s Unity.
And that will give
you specific callbacks
from your app running in Unity.
So here I just have
a small, little debug
log that every time I change
the orientation from portrait
to landscape, it just
outputs a debug message
within my console in the app.
And as I'm running this on my
phone, and as it's connected,
you can actually see these
callbacks through ADB.
Now, it'll also output things
like errors or null reference
exceptions, which, if you've
developed a lot of applications
in Unity, you know you
always get those a lot
where certain things
aren't hooked up,
or certain things aren't
initialized before you're
trying to call them.
And you can get that
information back via ADB.
So you can start tracing
and understanding
where those issues
are coming from.
All right, and now
what I want to do
is talk a little bit about
reducing the size of your APK.
So within Unity,
and just really when
building any sort
of application,
especially in the
mobile ecosystem,
you know that how fast
your user can actually
play and experience your
game is crucial in getting
them to be retained and
continue to play it.
And so part of this is a
strategy for delivering
a small APK, or a
small application,
that they can get
started with right away,
they can download
not over Wi-Fi,
and they can really
just start experiencing.
So for this, there's a
couple different strategies
both built into Unity and
the Google Play Store.
And I want to talk about
how you, as a developer,
can start taking
advantage of those.
All right, so the first
one is splitting the APK
by target architecture.
Now, this is a little
bit of a newer function.
So it's available in the latest
version of Unity in 2018.2.
So that's the latest stable
release, available now.
And what it allows
you to do is it
allows you to check which
APK target architectures
you specifically want when
you build out your app.
Now, the Play Store
actually allows
you to upload different
versions of the APK
for all these target
architectures.
And then, depending
on what device
you're on and what target
architecture it has,
it will actually download
these separate APKs.
Previously, inside Unity, when
you would package up an APK,
you would target
certain architectures,
and it would all
kind of be combined
into a single APK,
which ended up bloating
your size a little bit.
So this is just an easy win
where you can separate things
out, and it'll output
different APKs depending
on which checkboxes you hit.
This is also a step
towards compliance
with things like
the new Android P,
as well as just
from requirements
as you start to
build out your apps.
The other thing
that's supported is
something called APK
expansion files, or OBB.
And what this is
is this is a way
to build a base
unit of your game--
think of something like the
main menu and the first couple
levels--
and then actually
split it up into what
we call expansion
files, which are
downloaded alongside your game.
And again, this is
a way for your users
to download your
application right away,
and then start feeding in
the necessary data to then
experience later levels.
If someone downloads
your app right now,
they might just want to
play the first couple levels
and not have to wait for the
entire thing to download,
or the entire size of your APK.
So how do you take advantage
of this within Unity?
Well, there's a small
checkbox there to build out
these OBB within the publish
settings under player settings.
Once you build this out,
it will actually, again,
kind of separate your APK.
And through the
Google Play Store,
you can upload these
alongside of it.
Now, because Android is
more of an open ecosystem,
you do have to be careful about
users deleting these OBB files.
And you can't
really restrict them
from cleaning up their
phone, deleting some things
to try to clear up maybe
space for another app
or something like that.
So it is required
that, if you do this,
you actually provide a way
for the user to re-download
these files within your app.
So how do you do this?
Well, Google provides
some documentation
on how to actually integrate
it on their side of things
for native applications.
And on the Unity
side, if you guys just
all want to take a picture
of this exact function
and call back.
And I was just kidding on that.
There's actually an
asset store package
here that we've written
that allows you to easily go
and integrate that
extra download that's
required if you do split up
your application using these OBB
files.
So again, this is a
setting built into Unity
to split up your
app in order to have
the main part of
the game, something
like the main menu and
the first couple levels,
and then expansion
files that complete
the rest of your application.
And the real goal
here is to try to get
under that 100-megabyte limit
so that your users are not
required to download
your app via Wi-Fi.
And so this, you can see,
is just the Google Play OBB,
and it's free on the
Unity asset store, which
just has this little
code snippet here,
as well as some sample
scenes and examples that
allows you to then put a
button into your app, which
is a requirement for the
Play Store when using that.
All right.
And now I want to talk a bit
about Google Play Instant.
So this was mentioned in
a lot of previous talks,
and it's something that I
think is really exciting
and kind of what's possible
in coming in the future.
So Google Play Instant
is a way for users
to try out your
game even quicker
it's a smaller,
bite-sized experience that
may be something
like a single level,
or really a taste of what your
full application and game can
be.
And how do you start
to integrate this,
or how do you build
this within Unity?
Well, Google's actually
made a plug-in.
It's still in beta.
But the cool thing
you can see here
is that it's very
actively being worked on.
I think this release--
says here that it was really
something like four days ago.
That was actually four days ago.
So eight days ago, this plug-in
was updated and released.
And it's really being
actively developed.
And it is kind of a
special part of the store
right now, where you can
give your users access to it.
Now to integrate this and
use this within Unity,
there is a lot of
additional steps and setups
that you need to go
through fairly carefully.
But Google has done
a really good job
of providing a menu here.
And it actually walks you
through the required steps.
You drop down the
Google Play Instant.
You can actually build to
the Instant architecture,
and then run that
on your device.
And it gives you this small,
little sample of your app
and packages it all up for you.
So this is directly
integrated into Unity.
So you can start taking
advantage of it now
and build these
instant play apps.
And that's pretty much it
for my talk, so thanks a lot.